bonjour gilbert roger merci beaucoup
merci merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation ce matin sur rtl france on va
parler évidemment de la gestion de la
crise sanitaire le directeur général de
la santé a dit hier dans le jdd que le
couvre-feu fonctionner très bien écouter
la situation est évidemment très tendu
le gouvernement a pris des mesures de
freinage forte en particulier avec le
couvre-feu ce dernier fonctionne très
bien
cette mesure répond bien la
problématique des rassemblements privé
et intéresse d'ailleurs beaucoup nos
voisins qui ont été surpris de ses
effets alors toujours un peu de l'auto
satisfecit que compensé vous écoutez je
pense que globalement le problème que
nous rencontrons en france c'est
l'absence de lits de réanimation et la
situation tendue des hôpitaux
donc le moindre sursaut du nombre de cas
qu vide est un drame
ramené à la place qu'il y a dans les
hôpitaux de france donc j'aurais
tendance à dire matt sinon vaccinant 26
noms à grande de grandes campagnes et la
difficulté c'est que une fois encore on
a le sentiment qu un secret d'état sur
les capacités de la france à avoir des
flacons de vaccin de vaccins disponibles
pour toutes les tranches d'âge or
justement en attendant est-ce que ça
annonce déconfinement locaux à l'instar
de nice août de dunkerque bientôt paris
où la seine saint denis
qu'est ce que vous en pensez à ce que le
gouvernement finalement préparent les
esprits
ils préparent les esprits parfois ses
propres ses improvisations
on a l'impression d'un d'un jeu de
d'improvisation comme le font les
canadiens dans les théâtres faudra y
retourner pour le voir quand on aura le
droit d'aller dans une salle de
spectacle c'est de l'impro
moi je demande plutôt que on soit en
capacité de vacciner notamment de
vacciner les jeunes quand les jeunes
tranche d'âge de 18 30 ans auront la
capacité d'être vacciné c'est le retour
immédiat la faculté ou dans les stages
en entreprise
on est ensemble en parler l allemagne a
décidé de façon assez brutale de et
unilatérale d'ailleurs de placer la
moselle en zone à risque contrôlé
strictement les déplacements en
provenance de ce département frontalier
ça a pris de court les élus regarder ce
qu'on a dit jean rottner le président du
conseil régional durant test on essayé
de bâtir quelque chose d'inédit au
niveau d'un espace de coopération
européen et on se fait rattraper par une
position qui est plutôt une position
centrale allemande
les chiffres de la moselle aujourd'hui
sont stables c'est largement au dessus
de ce qu'accepte l'allemagne ont
commencé vous de cette décision
allemande
elle est la traduction réelle de la
faiblesse européenne à répondre à la
crise sanitaire
quand vous voyez que on met déjà
pratiquement trois semaines a validé la
mise sur le marché des vaccins alors aux
états unis au canada au royaume uni qui
est sortie de l'union européenne ça
c'est quasi immédiat eh bien ça vous
donne la traduction c'est à dire chacun
fait ce qu'il veut dans son coin et j'ai
eu un collègue sénateur de la moselle au
téléphone
hier c'était incompréhensible pour eux
alors qu'il y a en plus énormément de
citoyens français qui travaillent de
l'autre côté de la frontière en
allemagne pouvoir au luxembourg
l'allemagne qui d'ailleurs s'était fait
épingler par l'union européenne sur sa
gestion déconfinement avec déconfinement
trop strict qu'est ce que vous en pensez
voilà c'est chacun fait ce qu'il veut
alors si c'est vraiment cela alors qu'on
nous laisse chercher à acheter nous
mêmes lots vaccin est en chacun des pays
façon ça règle si on veut être dans un
espace européen de promotion de la santé
des citoyens il faut que les règles
soient communes est admise par tous de
la même façon les la campagne de tests
salivaires a commencé aujourd'hui dans
les écoles de la zone c pensez vous que
c'est une des façons aussi de sortir de
cette crise oui si ça permet
effectivement de détecter puis après
d'isoler et de soigner et notamment pour
les très jeunes enfants chez je pense
que ce sera beaucoup plus facile mais et
je vais revenir sur la sphère de la
vaccination
j'ai lu dans la presse hebdomadaire
pourquoi les médecins de ville ne
prennent pas le fameux vaccin
astrazeneca est bien parce que en même
temps la france a édicté une petite
règle qui n'existe nulle part mais on a
des technocrates qui ont réussi à le
faire il faut certifier le réfrigérateur
dans lequel on met les médicaments les
vaccins
et bien c'est quoi la certification et
le médecin il va falloir qu'ils achètent
un un frigo spécial voyez à chaque fois
on peut commencer à faire des choses
mais ce résultat des courses ça fait 10
mille médecins qui ont refusé d'être
eux-mêmes vaccinateurs parce que on pose
une règle qui n'existe nulle part et
qu'il n'est demandée par personne à part
des spécialistes de la rs qui travaille
que sur des bureaux et avec des feuilles
de papier alors dans l'actualité de ce
lundi également c'est le déplacement des
manuels macron instance pour favoriser
l'insertion des jeunes situation très
compliquée pour les étudiants français
vous voyez cette étudiante à nice elle a
lancé un appel au secours à emmanuel
macron sur les réseaux sociaux regarder
les étudiants sont en train de mourir à
l'aide
je suis étudiante en dix ans en
alternance et je touche 780 euros par
mois je paie un loyer de 560 euros
on vient de me baisser mon appel de 271
euros à 33 euros et je n'ai pas de prime
d'activités dites moi comment je peux me
nourrir et payer tous les frais
quotidiens de la vie alors de plus en
plus de jeunes en font part de leur
mal-être sur les réseaux sociaux est ce
que selon vous il faudra envisager un
confinement plus souple pour les jeunes
et laisser des étudiants revenir en cour
moi je suis pour que les jeunes
retournent en cours il faut leur
permettre de le faire et je pense que
chaque université est en capacité de
déterminer le nombre instantanée
d'étudiants dans un amphi pouvoir dans
une salle de t d est ensuite d'organiser
des rotations et en même temps il faut
que l'on permette d'aller vacciner dans
toutes les universités
tous ces jeunes s'ils ont rapidement une
dose d'astrazeneca qu'il leur est
attribuée vous verrez que comme en
israël comme au canada comme au
royaume-uni enfin en
l'étude écossaise le monde nous allons
faire descendre chuter le la difficulté
liée à kovy de 10,9 tout de suite que
coco qu'attendez-vous du de la visite
emmanuel macron à stains aujourd'hui
justement pour l'insertion des jeunes
oui alors déjà un je suis surpris de ça
me permet d'avoir le plaisir d'être avec
vous mais on a été
nous les parlementaires informé de la
venue du président de la république mais
pas conviés à y participer il ce qui est
une drôle de façon de respecter la
tradition républicaine qui veut clore ce
qu'un président de la république se
déplace dans un département
les parlementaires soient conviés une
fois que shelly ça qu'est ce qu'il va
faire il va venir faire une photo avec
quelques jeunes triés sur le volet et
puis une association liée à total qui
fait 2 2 du contact entre des jeunes à
la recherche d'un emploi ou d'un stage
et des majeurs comme l'on dit dans dans
les entreprises tant mieux ça existe ça
se fait est ce que ça peut se développer
et être un peu plus efficace pourquoi
pas est-ce que ça mérite le déplacement
présidentiel point d'interrogation
les ministres de l'intérieur de la
justice et d'éducation nationale qui ont
demandé à convoquer les préfets
aujourd'hui pour réactiver le plan de
lutte contre les bandes en seine saint
denis ce problème vous vous le
connaissez est-ce que ils ont raison
d'activer ce plan qui avait déjà été
refondu en 2018 après des rixes dans le
19e arrondissement par christophe
castaner mais on a vu le résultat
pour l'instant ça marche pas oui mais
voilà tout ce qui pourrait être fait
pour éviter la formation de bande et
leurs organisations ultra violence doit
s'organiser
mais il ya aussi on l'a vécu en drame a
bondi vendredi
il faut aussi lutter efficacement contre
le drame de cet ultra violence du
quotidien
et puis on l'a vu pourquoi pourquoi des
jeunes avec des armes
enfin quand on a 17 et 23 ans et qu'on
arrive à se procurer une arme qui permet
de tuer un autre c'est c'est là dessus
aussi qu'on attend une réponse du
ministère de l'intérieur
la réponse est souvent la question du
renfort des policiers on en voit
davantage de policiers ont créé de
nouvelles unités
ça marche pas visiblement non parce que
ce qu'il n'ya plus c'est un peu ce qu'on
appelait les renseignements généraux
à mon époque lorsque j'étais maire de
bondy il y avait des contacts précis
avec ces fonctionnaires qui connaissait
bien le terrain d'abord parce qu'ils
étaient affectés dans la ville pour
plusieurs années 4 5 ans minimum
donc on avait cette parfaite
connaissance peu et nous des difficultés
locales et nous essayons de les traiter
là on a une police qui est trop a mené à
une mobilité qui est amenée à des tâches
[Musique]
multiples qui est incompréhensible pour
les policiers eux mêmes ce qui fait que
ils sont débordés et peuvent pas
s'attacher à la protection de ce qu'on
appelle la vie du quotidien et ça c'est
pas une caméra qui rend service et qui
fait le travail non il faut que ce soit
par des contacts pour que les choses se
fassent correctement
je lisais dans la presse ce matin
que sur le drame de bondy il y avait une
médiation qui avait été un gars faites
notamment l'espace mandela qu'on voit
sur les écrans de votre télé c'est pas
non plus à des animateurs de maisons de
quartier d'être dans la médiation
lorsqu'il y à l'ultraviolence entre des
jeunes
il faut que la plainte soit déposée il
faut que les les contacts avec police et
justice puisse organiser et puis lé rôle
les parents qu'est ce que vous voulez en
personne n'en parle mais j'avais mis en
place une maison des parents pour aider
à ce qu'on appelait le retour de
l'autorité parentale parce que j'étais
agacé du fait que ce soient toujours les
grands frères qui viennent régler les
affaires de la famille ben ça recommence
et voilà vendredi c'est un grand frère
qui est venu à battre un autre c'est
inadmissible et révoltant merci à
l'unisson merci beaucoup
gilbert roger vous avoir répondu en
direct à nos questions ce matin sur rtl
france